the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay I think things have been getting
pretty derp IV lately so I wanted to
shift gears to something a little bit
more practical so I started alluding to
this hypothetical radiation source I
might have right here and things like if
you have a source of known activity
which we calculated yesterday and you
have a detector of unknown efficiency
how do you know what the efficiency is
how do you know what let's say your dose
distance relationship is and how do you
calculate all this stuff so let's take
the general situation that were starting
to work out let's say we have a Geiger
counter right here that's our GM tube
and we have a point source it's emitting
things in all directions let's go with
this stuff from yesterday let's say it's
a cobalt-60 source right that was it's
now zero point five two micro Curie the
question is how many counts do you
expect in this detector when it's a
certain distance away so I've actually
laser cut out a little Geiger counter
jig from a previous class and you guys
can all do this too who here has been to
the IDC before couple the International
Design Center so they've got a laser
cutter that you can sign up to use which
is where I did this and it's set to just
take a Geiger counter and put your
sources at some fixed distance away so
you can discover the dose distance
relationship with things
speaking of does anybody know what the
relationship is between dose and
distance or measured activity and
distance yeah Luke close it's let's say
the measured activity would be
proportional to one of the 1 over R
squared now who knows where this comes
from
I'll move the source a bit away to
lessen the beeping
yeah yeah exactly if you were to draw
hypothetical sphere around this source
right here then you've got a let's say
you've got a detector that's roughly
rectangular with a fixed area let's say
it's got a half length L and a half
width W then the area I'm sorry let's
just say length L which W the area would
be just L times W and actually what's
what Chris mentioned as the solid angle
subtended by this detector right here as
in other words at a certain distance R
away how much of this sphere how much of
the area of this sphere does this
detector take up in other words how many
of these gamma rays are going to go in a
different direction than the detector
versus how many will actually enter the
detector and a simple formula for the
solid angle is just the surface area of
whatever you've got over R squared it's
kind of a it's a pretty good
approximation to the solid angle of
something for very long distances and
it's probably the one that you'll see in
the reading but I wanted to show you the
actual formula in this case for a
rectangle solid angle comparison good
that's up there so on the let's say on
the x axis right here this would be
distance from the source to the detector
in meters and I've said that we've got
some sort of a detector that is 2.5 by
10 meters in size that's an enormous
detector let's actually switch it to the
units right here so this is roughly 10
centimeters long so let's change our
length to 0.1 and what's you think the
width of this Geiger counter is in
meters
centimeter 0.01 we're gonna have to
change our axes so we can actually see
the graph so instead of looking all the
way up to 15 meters away
let's look one meter away maybe less
this whole thing is probably 50
centimeters and we'll take a look there
and what we notice is that except for
extremely short distances this
approximate formula for the solid angle
or in other words if I were to draw a
sphere around this source that's the
radius of the distance between the
source and the detector how much of that
spheres area does the Ted Tector take up
this actual formulas approximate formula
the blue curve is a pretty good
approximation of the red curve until you
get really really close to like five
centimeters away or about this distance
right here so anyone know why this
formula would break down what happens as
R goes to zero what happens to our solid
angle or our approximation for our solid
angle
goes to infinity right Kenneth detector
actually take up infinity area on
anything
never mind that unit sphere not quite if
you were to take this detector and bring
the radius down to zero so that the
source and the detector if not counting
for the thickness of the plastic were
right up side each other if that solid
angle went to will infinity then the
count should go to infinity and does not
compute does anyone know how many first
of all who's here has heard of solid
angle before so a little more than half
of you so solid angle is kind of the
that's getting clicky I'm going to turn
that off solid angle is kind of the
analog to regular old angle except in 3d
so instead of looking at things in
radians this has the unit of what's
called ster radians d radians with a
full sphere taking up for pi ster
radians
interestingly enough for pi is also the
surface area of a unit sphere with
radius of one so that's where this comes
from
if something were to completely cover a
unit sphere like if you were to let's
say in case a light source in tin foil
completely and say how much of that
solid angle does the tin foil in case it
would be 4 pi ster radians regardless of
the size of the sphere how much tin foil
you had to use so this pretty simple
formula isn't the best approximation for
it and I'm not going to go through the
derivation because like I said today is
going to be of a more practical nature
there is a more complex and rigorous
formula for the solid angle of something
let's say in this case a rectangle of
length L and width W from a certain
distance R or in this case on our graph
X away from the sphere and you can
actually see that red curve right there
once you get to a few centimeters away
it's pretty close anyone want to guess
what the maximum value of the red curve
is
if I take this source and slam it right
up next to the detector how much of the
detector is I'm sorry how much of that
sphere the detector subtending to PI
half the sphere because it's this let's
say this whole side of the source is
completely obscured by the Tector and
this whole side is free to move and if
you look really closely yep at zero the
correct formula does give you 2 pi sir
radians which is to say that half the
gamma rays leaving this source would
enter the detector I didn't say anything
about get counted yet that's where the
detector efficiency comes in and that's
something we're gonna be measuring today
which is why I have my big bag of burnt
bananas these are the ashes of roughly
50 pounds of bananas charred to a crisp
at about 250 Fahrenheit for 12 hours in
most of the dorms and a couple of the
frat houses so last year I had the
students everyone take home about 50
pounds of bananas or 50 bananas I forget
which one it was a lot and we did some
distributed labor so everybody peeled
the bananas put them in the oven baked
them separated off the tin foil baked
off as much water and sugar as possible
to concentrate the potassium-40
in the bananas so there's a reason I've
been using potassium-40 has a lot of
examples in this class because you're
full of it that's pretty much the short
answer of it if you eat bananas which I
think most of you guys do you're in
taking a fair bit of radioactive
potassium which is a positron emitter
and also does electron capture and all
that fun stuff
so today what we're gonna be doing is
calculating the activity of one banana
but that's kind of a very difficult
thing to do so anyone know how
radioactive one banana actually is in
any units at all whatever it is it's
very very very very little one banana
contains a minuscule but measurable
amount of radioactivity and one of the
ways to boost your confidence on any
sort of radiation measurement is to
boost your signal strength or to boost
your counting time and because I don't
want to count for the next seven years
we've concentrated the ashes of 50
pounds of bananas and he
to boost your signal strength which is
going to boost your count rate which is
the intro I want to give to statistics
certainty and counting so let's take the
one of the homework problems as a
motivating example you guys does anyone
notice the extra credit problem on the
homework let's start talking about how
we go about that that should motivate
the rest of the day so I'll pull up that
problem set number four which by the way
is due Thursday not Tuesday because we
have no class on Tuesday that was a
surprise to me but whatever I'll still
be here we don't get holidays just you
guys so bonus question go do this so we
all know that smoking is a major source
of radioactivity and if you think about
it it's not just the smoke that contains
those radiation particles it's got to be
the cigarettes cigars and other smokable
--zz themselves and so I was thinking
there's no better concentrated source of
smoking radioactivity than a smoke shop
there's one out of a alewife at the end
of the teeth is probably of some closer
to campus but I know there's a whole
bunch that are tea accessible and so I
was thinking it'd be neat for us to find
out how radioactive is it to work in a
smoke shop because there's all these
radon decay oh yeah
you actually know
are you serious but you got to be 18 to
smoke interesting we may have to leave
the city for this what about Somerville
[Music]
berries yeah I don't think it is where
I'm from Swampscott I don't think it's
uh I don't think it's 21 but that's kind
of up on the commuter rail so you don't
to go to Swampscott at any rate I would
think that okay it's probably a fairly
radioactive place to work but the
question is how long would you actually
have to bring a detector in and count in
order to be sure that there's any sort
of measurable difference and so without
deriving all of the stuff about binomial
poison and normal statistics I'll say
that's in the reading for today I want
to show you some practical uses and
applications of this stuff let's say you
were to measure some count rate in some
experiment and we'll put this in units
of counts per minute which would be the
number of counts divided by the counting
time that's about as simple as it gets
from Poisson statistics you can say that
the standard deviation of that count
rate is actually just the square root of
the count rate divided by time and
that's kind of the simple thing right
here but usually in these sorts of
experiments if you want to know how much
more radioactive is one place than
another you have to take a background
count so if I wanted to know how much
activity that source was giving off
there is lots of background radiation
that we'll be going over in about a
month I would have to sit here for quite
a while and wait for the slow clicks of
whatever background radiations in the
room there we go to cause to get enough
of a count rate going on you can imagine
the slower the count rate the less
certain you can be that the number that
you're measuring is actually accurate so
the idea here is that this standard
deviation
is a measure of confidence that your
values actually right so the two things
that you can do let's yeah the two
things you can do to decrease this
standard deviation you could increase
your counting time right those looks
like why is there a C on top that
doesn't look right it actually is okay
yeah yeah there we go
so by Counting for longer you can
decrease your standard deviation this is
going to take forever
it actually takes about 67 minutes
because we've already done this
calculation to get a 95% confidence on
5% uncertainty for this sort of
background count I mean how many concept
we had so far like 12 14 yeah not very
many then you've got to be able to
subtract that count rate from whatever
your source actually is and the way that
you actually measure this is pretty
straightforward the May the way that you
do error subtraction is not as
straightforward so let's say we're going
to separate these two experiments into a
background experiment which we're
actually going to do in an hour when we
want to count these banana ashes we're
gonna have to put we're gonna have to
count radiation coming from the detector
itself which will account for cosmic
rays contamination in the detector
whatever else might have been spilled in
there from previous samples and we're
also going to take some sort of gross
count rate background which will be our
background plus the net count rate of
our actual source and that's what we're
going for so the net count rate is
pretty easy just the gross count rate
minus the background let's keep the
symbols the same minus the background
count rate does anyone know how to
quantify the uncertainty of this net
count rate you just add the two
anyone
well in this case we have to account for
the fact that radiation emission from
anything is a truly random process so
it's actually random you there is no
correlation between when one particle
leaves and the next particle is going to
leave and because it's a truly random
process these errors in the background
rate and the growth rate could add
together or could subtract from each
other in other words one might be a
little higher than it should be one
might be a little lower than it should
be if you just add together the two
standard deviations you actually always
get an over estimate of the true error
because you're not accounting for the
fact that these two experiments may have
partially canceling errors so in this
case this that would be your worst case
scenario which is not your most likely
scenario what you actually want is to do
what's called uncertainty in quadrature
where you actually add up the sum of the
square roots of those errors kind of
looks like the magnitude of a vector
doesn't it kind of looks exactly like
the magnitude of a vector so in this way
you're accounting for the fact that more
error in each experiment does increase
the error on whatever net experiment
you're doing but not linearly because
sometimes you have partially canceling
errors and with enough statistics if you
count for long enough or you count
enough counts then these things on
average are going to add in quadrature
which will come out to and I want to
make sure you don't have any typos so
I'll just keep the notes with me so you
need the background count over the
background x squared plus those there we
go and so now I'd like to pose a
question to you the same one that's here
in the in the what is it and the problem
set how long do you have to count in the
smoke shop to be 95% sure that let's say
your counter eights 5 percent uncertain
and we're going to spend the rest of
today's class taking apart that
statement and getting at what it should
be so again what we want to say is how
do you know that we're 95
percent confident of our count rate plus
or minus five percent error that's the
main question for today does anyone know
how we'd start anyone get to the reading
today see some smiles okay we'll start
from scratch then all right so who's
here has heard of a normal distribution
before Wrigley LA to you guys great the
idea here is that with enough counting
statistics this very rare event binomial
distribution approaches a normal
distribution where you can say if you
measure a certain count rate let's say
this would be your mean count rate and
if you measure some other count rate to
limits of plus or minus 1 Sigma or one
standard deviation 1 Sigma gives you
about 68% confidence in your result
confident ya spelled it right the reason
for that is that if you go plus or minus
1 Sigma away from your true average
right here you filled in 68 percent of
the area under this normal distribution
similarly if you go plus 2 Sigma or
minus 2 Sigma it's around 95% confident
3 Sigma is getting towards 99 point what
was the number again I think it's 6
maybe it's more like 98.5 percent and
then so on and so on and so on there's
actually society is called Six Sigma
societies and the way that they get
their name is we're so
confident of things we can predict them
to Six Sigma which is some ninety-nine
point a large number of nines percentage
of the area under a normal distribution
so if I ask you how long do you have to
count to be 95% confident in your result
you have to give an answer that will
relate two times this standard deviation
and now we know the formula for standard
deviation of this net counting
experiment so we can formulate our
equation dust Li let's say in order to
be 95% confident in other words - Sigma
that our counting rate is within five
percent of the actual value in other
words plus or minus five percent error
we put our error percentage here and our
true net count rate there so this part
right here tells us the 95 percent
confidence this part right here is our
five percent error that part right there
is our count rate so then we can
substitute in our expression for Sigma
our uncertainty in quadrature and find
out things like well depends on what the
information were given is let's say
before you go to the smoke shop
you take your Geiger counter and for an
extremely long time you count the
background counts somewhere so let's say
in this problem the known quantities we
know our background count rate because
you can do that at your leisure at home
and when I did to this that came out to
about 25 counts per minute and known is
the background counting time and when I
did this to get within 95% confidence of
5% error had to do this for 67 minutes
and now all that's left is we want to
relate our net count rate and our gross
counting time or our gross count rate in
our gross counting time because it's
like the same thing so this is actually
how you decide
how long you have to sit in the smoke
shop to count in order to satisfy what
we asked for 95% confidence that your
counter eight is five percent error so
let's start substituting this out that's
not mine so we can get rid of that
so we'll take that expression and
substitute it everything we can so 0.05
CN equals to Sigma and there's our Sigma
expression it's all rewrite right here
so we have C V over T V squared + cg /
TG squared okay what's next
how do we relate TG and CG
well let's start with the easy stuff
right what can we cancel or square or
whatever just somebody yell it out
yep so we have numbers for C B and T B
but not C G and T G we have not yet
answered the question when you go into
the smoke shop and talk to the owner and
he says fine you're gonna sit here with
a radiation detector how long do you
have to be here looking all weird you
want to have an answer and so if you get
some initial estimate of CG you can tell
him this is my approximate T G at which
point he or she you'll say yes or no
depending on how they're feeling so why
don't we just start / - right / - 0.025
we can square both sides and there's a
CN there square both sides we end up
with 0.006 - 5 CN squared equals CB / T
V squared plus C G / TG squared there's
lots of ways to go about it I want to
make sure I do the efficient one oh I'm
sorry
those aren't Squared's because those are
already our standard deviations had the
square root in them there we go that's
more like it
okay what's next
we got too many variables yeah
we're going
isn't there still a what because in this
case the standard deviation is the
square root of the count rate over the
time so the standard deviation squared
is just count rate over time was there
in Perley or expression we have to
correct yup that's where it came from
that's right that's not because that's
right there we go good good tracing out
that okay now that everything is
corrected here what's next we got too
many variables yeah not quite because
there's a count rate in here so the
units of standard deviation if this is
square root of count rate over time
which is the same as number of counts
times time over time right yeah because
again account rate is I'm sorry is a
number over - uh where'd it go yeah
number over x squared that doesn't sound
right though let's see
hold on I think
although the standard deviations got to
have the same units as the count rate
itself because they're they're additive
right because they usually expressed
some count rate plus or minus either
Sigma or two Sigma's that they've got to
have the same count rate so standard
deviations are expressed in counts per
minute if your counts are expressed in
counts per in it okay cool
so you got too many variables but it's
easy to get rid of one of them either CN
or CG do you have a question great okay
so you're gonna say the same thing that
I was gonna do cool
so we'll take out our CN and we'll stick
in a CG minus CB okay and we're trying
to isolate T G as a function of CG or
vice versa there's a lot of C G's and
not a lot of T geez so let's just keep
the TG on its own so we'll have 0.000
six-to-five cg minus CB squared and I'm
going to subtract CB over TB from both
sides minus CB over TB equals cg / TG
and do I have to go through the rest of
the math with you guys think at this
point we've got it pretty much solved we
divide everything by CG flip it over and
you end up with actually I've already
written out the expression which I want
to show you guys here back to smoke shop
counting time so I want to show you some
of the implications of this expression
that number right there is just a more
exact part a bit of to Sigma instead of
0.05 and let's see yeah instead of 0.05
we had something much much closer so
what I want us to look at is this graph
right here we've got a nice relation now
between the count rate in counts per
minute and the require was of the gross
count rate and the required counting
time to get to that five percent
uncertainty
well there's a couple of interesting
bits about this equation what are some
of the features you notice yeah
yes if the count rate is extremely low
it's going to take an infinite amount of
time you're actually right on some
levels so if we have that expression
right there
so let me just actually get it all the
way out so we can see because I want to
show you some of the math related
implications for this so if we had our
counting time is what do we have
CG over 0.0 let's say 2 5 CG minus CB
squared minus CB over TB at what point
is this equation undefined
yes that's right for the condition
so like Sean said for the condition
where 0.025 CG minus CB let's just call
it C net squared minus equals CB over TB
this equations actually undefined which
means that if your CB and TV let's say
if the uncertainty whoops
stepped on the cord if your uncertainty
from your background counting great
experiment is such that you can never
get the total uncertainty down to let's
say five percent error with 95 percent
confidence you can't actually run that
experiment because these uncertainties
are added in quadrature if you're trying
to reduce Sigma down to a value below
that already how can you do that you
can't have a negative standard deviation
right so what this actually means is
that when you're designing this
experiment even if you count for 67
minutes at 25 counts per minute like we
can now out in the air that might not be
enough to discern the activity of the
smoke shop or the source or whatever you
happen to be looking at to 95 percent
confidence within 5 percent error and so
let's actually look at that on the graph
if we keep on scrolling up just by
adding stuff to the y-axis eventually we
see that it gets all straight and right
here at about 49 counts a minute
suspiciously close to the background
counts you'll never actually be able to
get within this confidence and error
interval so there's always some
trade-offs you can make in your
experiment let's see there it is so the
sometimes do you necessarily have to be
95% confident of your result depends on
what you're doing or do you necessarily
have to get within 5% error that's
probably the one you can start to
sacrifice the first so usually you want
to be confident of whatever result
you're saying and be
confident that you're giving acceptable
bounce so you can remain at 95%
confidence which means where that heart
go yeah over here which means keep your
to Sigma but you can then increase your
allowable percent error so if you can't
get within 5% error and I believe the
homework doesn't actually say that for a
reason yeah we don't tell you whatever
to choose but we do say try to get to
95% confidence so then the question is
for a reasonable counting time how what
- what error can you get within 95%
confidence the more air you allow the
shorter time you have to account for and
I want to show you graphically how some
of that stuff interplays at each other
let's say you were to increase your
counting time which we can do here with
this slider so for the same background
counting rate if you increase the
counting time what happens to the
uncertainty on your background
experiment does it go up down or nothing
it's gonna go down yeah count for longer
the uncertainty goes down I'm gonna have
to change the bounds here to something
more reasonable so we were at 67 minutes
and now notice as you increase your
counting time even though you haven't
changed the counting rate it then takes
less time to distinguish whatever your
source is so let's say count for less
time in the background you have to count
for more time in the experiment until it
just kind of explodes count for more
time in the background you have to count
for less time in the experiment in order
to get to the uncertainty in confidence
you want to get to so like if you
doubled your background count time from
67 minutes to 134 then you can measure
count rates as low as 42 counts per
minute growths so when you start going
into the smoke shop you can let's say
count for a few minutes get some very
crude estimate of the counting rate and
then decide how long you have to let
your background accumulate so you can
distinguish
the activity in the smoke shop - within
some confidence in some error yes
it's definitely location dependent so we
will get into background counts and
sources of background radiation in about
a month but to give you a quick
flash-forward depends on your elevation
to say how much of the atmospheres
protect you from cosmic rays definitely
depends on location so in New Hampshire
the background counts quite a bit higher
because there's a lot of granite
deposits and granite can be upwards of
52 parts per million uranium um
radium Conway granite in particular
named after Conway New Hampshire is
pretty rich in radium or where you're
from oh there you go okay yeah it's also
neat you can use you can use background
counts as a radiation altima tur one of
my graduate students actually built a
Geiger counter interface to an Arduino
where you could actually tell what the
height you were flying at is by the
amount of background radiation increase
so certainly it's going to depend where
you are right but you want to make sure
that you're in an area to answer Shawn's
question representative of where the
smoke shop is so you can't go into the
reactor and drop this in the core and
say I'm doing a background count that's
not enough that's not a valid experiment
so yeah you'd want to be I don't know
same block right that would be pretty
good and then go in there and see can
you measure any sort of increase get a
crude estimate of your CG your gross
count rate use this formula right here
to estimate how much time you'd have to
wait so for example let's shrink our
y-axis down a little and be more
optimistic than we probably should let's
say you go in there and you get a count
rate of a hundred counts per minute that
would that would surprise me you'd only
have to count for an extra 28 minutes to
nail that net count rate with 95%
confidence to five percent error let's
say now what happens if we increase the
allowable percent error so let's say 10
percent error would be acceptable we
just take that number double it then all
of a sudden you don't have to count for
nearly as long so again at five percent
error which means 0.25 here
at a hundred counts per min
you'd have to count for well about 30
minutes if you're willing to accept 10
percent error that goes down to 7
minutes and 18 seconds so do you guys
see the general interplay between
confidence percent error counting time
and counting rate who hears built an NSA
Geiger counter before awesome so this is
definitely a try it at home kids kind of
thing if you want to find out is
something radioactive this is what you
can actually use to find out answer the
question is it discernibly radioactive
to within some limit of error or limit
of confidence that's what we're gonna be
doing here with a much much much more
sensitive detector so the only thing
missing from our complete picture of
going from the activity of a source
which we've shown you how to count to
dealing with the solid angle which is
just a simple formula to dealing with
statistics and uncertainty is now the
efficiency of this detector out of the
number of radiation quanta or whatever
that enter the detector
how many interact and how many leave out
the other side that's what we're gonna
be spending most of the next month on
when we do ion photon electron and
neutron interactions with matter so
we'll find out what's the probability
per unit length that each one undergo
that interaction what kind of
interactions do they undergo and then
we'll complete this actual picture so
you can take a source of let's say
unknown activity put in a known distance
away from a known detector with a known
efficiency and back out what the
activity of that source is with accuracy
that's what you're going to start doing
on this homework as well for the banana
lab well the only thing you don't know
is the activity of this bag of bananas
but we're going to give you all the
information like the efficiency of the
detector and the geometry of the
detector and you're going to be able to
measure the number of potassium-40
counts that the detector picks up so by
taking let's see for us we have some
space left
we had a little bit here so by taking
that number of counts and dividing by
let's say the efficiency of the detector
where that efficiency is going to range
from zero to one probably much closer to
zero and also dividing by let's say your
solid angle over 4pi to account for how
many of the emitted potassium-40 gamma
rays actually get into the detector and
dividing by two gamma rays per
disintegration I think that's what we
had last time or was that cobalt-60 yeah
we've been using cobalt-60 as an example
so remember we had two gamma rays
emitted per cobalt-60 disintegration on
average then you can get to the actual
activity of the source once you know the
activity of this bag of bananas you can
then divide by either the mass of one
banana or the number of bananas or
whatever to get the final answer that's
we're gonna spend the rest of today
doing so since it's getting on 505 of do
you guys have any questions about what
we cover today or what we're about to go
do
[Music]
not necessarily let's say you were to
encase your detector in an infinite
medium of radiation material right then
you could subtract every single
gamma-ray your solid angle would be four
pi so if your solid angle is four pi
then that would equal ish the area over
r-squared of your thing but this is
actually not that good of an
approximation when you put a source very
very up close to a detector so there are
actual formulas for solid angle where
the the real formula for solid angle you
actually end up having to do a surface
integral of the sine let's say the which
accounts for the fact that the object
that you have might be lets say tilted
towards or away from the detector times
some differential D theta D was it D Phi
D theta of this unit sphere so you'll
have to integrate to say how many of
these little D 5 D Thetas are actually
subtended by your detector and the value
of that actual surface integral gives
you the real solid angle that's the
super simple x1 if you just know the
area of something and you know that
you're kind of far away but again
whenever possible use the exact formula
so any other questions yeah Shawn
the two gammas / cobalt-60 this one that
accounts for the fact that if you
remember the decay diagram for cobalt-60
how does that decay by beta emission it
goes to one energy level and it tends to
go down by two Danna gamma decays to
nickel 60 so each time it gives off a
gamma ray to one level and a gamma ray
to another level so in this case one
Becker l of cobalt 60 would give off two
gamma rays per second so if you are
measuring a number of counts of each
count one gamma ray was responsible you
have to then divide by the number of
gamma rays per disintegration on average
in order to get the actual activity of
that source so member activity is
measured in disintegrations not in
number of gamma rays emitted that's the
difference here dose you'd actually care
about how many gamma rays you absorb but
activity is how many atoms are
disintegrating per second yeah yeah
the units of cobalt-60 oh this would be
like atoms of cobalt-60
and those gamma rays would be gammas per
atom so in this case it's like - sorry -
gamma rays per atom of cobalt-60
disintegrating or better yet per
disintegration so you've got to know
what material you're looking at in order
to know how many gammas are how many
betas or more that you're gonna get per
disintegration who hears heard of this
uncertainty and quadrature before this
couple folks okay yeah the idea here is
that again if you just add the arrows up
you're probably over estimating the
error and selling yourself short
cool that case if there's no questions
let's go do this so follow me to the
counting lab
okay so this is my counting lab these
are three high purity germanium
detectors have you explained high purity
germanium detectors okay have you
explained any detectors okay well here
down in here there's a little high
purity germanium crystal with a couple
thousand volts across it when a gamma
ray goes into it make some electron hole
pairs nod when I say electron hole pairs
okay good
and basically you get more hole electron
hole pairs the more energy of the gamma
you have so you collect the current from
that and you know you get a little pulse
of current and the height of the pulse
tells you how many hole pairs you had
and then back it up to what the energy
of your gamma was that works fine if you
collect all of the gamma energy you
don't always quite do that but anyway so
that's how the United are y'all can
scoop shop if there's not a whole lot to
see in there but it's worth a look I
mean there's not you can't really see
the crystal there's just a aluminum
cylinder in there the black part is just
a carbon fiber window because you don't
want to cut off the low-energy gammas so
it's got a really thin carbon fiber
window on it
what's with the hundreds of pounds of
copper on the side there's not a
hundreds of pounds of copper on this
side these guys are LED which does two
things it shields the detectors from the
activity out here from you guys from the
activities coming out of here because
sometimes I'm counting very low activity
samples and it also if I'm counting
something that has a lot of activity it
shields us from that activity so it kind
of goes both ways
the reason there's copper is if you get
a high-energy gamma ray into some lead
it makes x-rays it makes it very nice
75k
you guys know KTV good awesome you makes
a really nice 75 ke V gamma x-ray that
interferes with trying to count things
around 75 k UV because we're getting all
these x-rays coming out of lid so you
line it with copper which makes a lower
energy x-ray and filters out the light
x-rays so anyway yeah so this is just
these I've got two germanium detectors
that one's also germanium it's a well
detector so it's got a little one
centimeter hole in it so if you can
stick a sample like right in the
germanium they're hooked up through in a
little electronic box and go into the
computer over there that does all a peak
height analysis oh yeah liquid nitrogen
Dewar thanks for pointing yeah you cool
the electronics and the dent everything
down so you cuts out the thermal noise
because you're looking for really tiny
little signals here so you cool
everything down and that way it's not
too noisy these guys are okay
warming up it doesn't destroy the
detector the old detectors you have to
keep cold all the time and if they
warmed up then they were just paper
weights but so this is just the counting
lab I've got an actual sample counting
in here right now we'll take a look at
the spectrum in a minute you're bananas
we're gonna go here and see if we can
yeah cuz it would be nice if I could
close the lid
oops almost well we'll smash this down I
know here wouldn't you guys do this you
smash that down till it fits in there
although don't break the bag oh okay
we'll get another bag it's okay it's
just banana ash
we'll find another bag it's okay
you know I'm all about I'm all about
making mistakes yeah yeah yeah just be a
little more gentle we'll throw some duct
tape on it and it'll be fine
so you're looking for potassium-40 in
your bananas correct where else do you
think we got potassium-40
or do you think there's any other
potassium-40 in the room Yeah right so
when you do the banana count we
frequently take a spectrum on this with
the lead closed and we always see
potassium-40 there's potassium-40
everywhere so after we get the count of
the bananas we'll take a background
count you'll want to subtract the two
signals your so ahead of me okay um I
think that's all but is this gonna fit
now okay
close enough
I've got this thing I've got a whole
bunch of little spacers if I'm counting
something that's hot and by hot I mean
radioactive hot I like you know I'll
space it out a little further
no that's fine we just got to close the
lid and okay if I've got something
that's very radioactive all just space
it out away from the detector if you've
got something that's really hot it just
kind of swamps out the electronics
there you go is there anything else I
want to say in here no let's move this
way this is the spectrum I'm collecting
on MIT one right now I don't know how
long has that been going half a day and
less than that anyway so this is a
sample of quartz that was irradiated
next to the reactor you guys are going
to do shorts in like a month
did you bring your samples okay good
anyway this is a sample of quartz that
was irradiated in the same spot you guys
are going to do your radiation sort of
in the graphite region of the reactor
the reason we're running it is the
people who are looking at this quartz
want to run it for 80 hours and we'd
like to know if there are any impurities
in it that'll cause grief meaning a lot
of activity when it comes out so we went
for a short period I think this ran six
hours and it's just a little tiny piece
and so I can look at the gamma spectrum
coming out of this so you can see
there's a whole mess of Peaks in here
this one yes see that - see that little
peak right there can you nod yeah okay
so that's the full spectrum that's the
peak that's a tungsten 1:87 peak so I
did put up one little thing right behind
you see that's the okay and have you all
seen the chart of the nuclides this
thing every day good I've got one of
these on every wall in every lab in
office and a little handbook yeah so the
tungsten 1-86 activates into tungsten
187 so I mean if you've looked at the
chart of the nuclides you can tell that
there's all the sort of parameters you
would need to calculate you know how
much activation you'd get based on
Neutron flux and time and cross the
twenty-eight point 43 that's the
abundance of that isotope you can see
the Sigma Gamma 38 that's the cross
section for thermal neutrons
and so that's how likely you'll get from
186 to one-eighty-seven one-eighty-seven
that's the half-life 23.9 hours so with
all of that and underneath the 23.9
you've got what the gammas are 685 479
it's got a whole mess of gamma so that's
a bunch of the gammas in here from that
so you could knowing how big that peak
is what the efficiency of the detector
is for collecting that peak in that
geometry it's the half-life the cross
set you know that whole mess of
parameters you could back calculate how
much tungsten is in the sample so that's
kind of how naa works which I assume
you've explained okay there you go
but that's not how I do anyway so right
right no no no so there's there's two
things you could do one of the things
you could do is you take all those
nuclear parameters and you calculate it
just from the peak height the other way
that everybody who does naa almost
everybody who does naa is you run a
standard material and if you guys
chemists anything put your life you all
took some chemistry at some point okay
so you've run a standard which means a
material that you know how much tungsten
is in it or how much a whole mess of
other things are so I run a bunch of
different standards so along with this
pizza piece of quartz I ran a standard
irradiated it at the same time I'll
count the quartz and then I'll count the
standard and by comparing the peak
heights and doing all the decay
Corrections and the weight Corrections
then I calculate how much tungsten is in
my sample so I don't actually use the
cross sections or the flux or any of
that other stuff all of those parameters
disappear notably the detector
efficiency disappears out of the
equation because that's the parameter
that you usually to have the fuzziest
idea about
and so you get you reduce the
uncertainty in your in your
concentration by doing this sort of
comparative method with a standard that
all makes sense okay yeah so when we run
shorts I guess in a month we'll take
whatever your samples are I've had
feedback about oh god you don't want to
run that many samples but we'll figure
out how many samples we'll run oh that's
a lot of shorts yeah so I'll show you
how the shorts get run so when we run
your shorts
we'll run your samples and we'll run
standards and then you can do the
comparative method or if you feel like
it you can do the other method depending
on what exercise you're gonna do the
other method you don't want to do this
standard method okay not practical well
if the computer goes down you can't get
any data anyway I can do the comparative
one on an envelope anyway
okay well we'll run standards or not
depending on how you guys are feeling
yeah so that's that oh right so let's
count your bananas okay so this is
detector two we did an energy
calibration earlier today so yeah
actually these are I've got a couple of
little button sources have you seen the
button sources yes so that's just a
couple of cobalt-60 lines and a
caesium-137 line down in here and I know
where those energies are so that just
gets used to calibrate the detectors
there you go there they are they're kind
of small there cuz my buttons are
probably 30 years old yeah so anyway so
we cleared that out and we just hit
start and we're not gonna see anything
for a while where are we anyway you are
banana peak will end up out in here
yeah so that's it'll take a while we're
gonna let this count till Tuesday
because why not I don't feel like coming
in over the weekend and turning it off
so so yeah so I mean this is just
picking up all the gammas coming out of
the bananas and everything else that
happens to get through the lid and all
the contamination on the inside of that
and we just let it count and then you
guys can calculate how much potassium-40
is in your ashes you'll need to do the
background subtraction I will give ya
I've got we collect background spectra
you know once a month or so so I'll give
you a background spectra
I will provide the efficiency for this
geometry which is pretty poorly defined
because I've got a program that'll do
that and I can't give you the program
and it's the pain in the neck to run
anyway if we've got a really
well-defined geometry that's not a big
bag usually I try to count sort of point
sources so I've got an efficiency
standard that I can use that I know what
the disintegrations in that are at a lot
of energies and I use that to do an
efficiency calibration usually but I
don't have an efficiency standard that's
that big it's just a point source I
think that's the practical naa from this
end that all makes sense I want you guys
to mad about him to nod yeah
my dessert well time because we were
just talking about this all week
good deal for neutron activation that's
kind of a real common part of the chart
so there's the manganese iron cobalt
nickel one of the things that you like
what you like usually when you're doing
naa is you want a nice thermal Neutron
spectrum you know what thermal Neutron
spectra means real slow neutrons and
they'll just give you sort of an n gamma
reaction so on that chart I earn fifty
eight iron 59
that's a nice you know in gamma reaction
and that's the one I use to analyze for
iron if you're near the reactor you're
also getting some fast neutrons which
can give you an NP reaction so if you're
looking on the chart there cobalt 59 if
you get an NP reaction will also make
the iron 59 and that's a pain in the
neck because then because if you've got
iron you've always got a little cobalt
floating around you maybe need to do a
correction so in practical terms when
you're running naa you really want to
have you want to avoid having all these
fast reactions there's usually an energy
threshold for the fast reactions like
one MeV PV or so yeah okay right the
place where we do the radiations is very
thermal got a very low fast spectrum so
I don't usually have to worry about that
there's a couple of times I actually use
the fast n P reaction if I want to
measure nickel you can see nickel 58 an
NP reaction to get your cobalt 58 and
since there's not a good reaction and
gamma from cobalt 57 cobalt 57 isn't
around usually so that's how I measure
nickel using an NP reaction and I need
to put the rabbits in to where I've got
a fast flux in the reactor which I got a
couple of spots for that I try not to
have to measure a nickel because it's
pain in the neck
but sometimes people want to know a
nickel and we talked a little about you
know what we've run in here four types
of samples every night okay
okay so back 15 20 25 years ago we did a
ton of environmental samples in this lab
we had a whole like three grad students
myself included who did atmospheric
particulate matter
rain water snow we even did some fog
collection which is kind of fun ice
cores which are old particulate
deposition and it was all for trace
elements in those kind of environmental
samples also lake sediments other
analytical methods have gotten a lot
better and so they've kind of caught up
to naa and you don't need a reactor to
run those so the environmental side of
this is kind of quieted down a lot but
it's still useful for a bunch of things
and so that's you know I do some work
here now I also work in the import group
so that's a lot of my time rather than
just this this lab practical things
let's go take a look at a couple other
labs you're not on wheels you don't have
a Steadicam okay okay you got a question
the weirdest thing I've been asked to
count that's already activated or okay
mm-hmm I don't know brain tissue fish
samples that we actually did the fresh
fish samples and you want to kind of
homogenized those and we had this kind
of titanium blender that you remember
the bass-o-matic we had this titanium
blender that we dropped the fish in and
you hook completely homogenized the fish
and then you took a little sample of it
and freeze-dried it and then analyzed it
for mercury
Yeah right cuz I mean you guys saw the
rabbits are only this big and the
samples I want are only that big and so
to get a representative fish you want to
kind of make a fish smoothie and then
take a sample out of that we did have a
guy who came to me and was promising he
we're gonna do this giant study using
fingernails and toenails for nutritional
analysis I mean he was working with a
group that looks at zinc deficiencies
and fingernails and toenails will give
you a good record of how much zinc
you've had over the last you know a week
or month or whatever depends where you
cut the nails and so I was going to get
you know a couple hundred African
children's toenails that didn't happen
but I did analyze my own toenails
well it's if you if you went to somebody
who was a little suspicious of you
asking for toenails is a lot easier than
asking for a blood sample because people
will give up toenails it's not a big
deal you all have you ever seen the
movie or read the book civil action
about the Superfund site in Woburn it
was a big old Superfund site and Woburn
had arsenic and chromium contamination
there used to be a lab I forget which
building it was in that did a ton of
research there one of the things we did
and in this lab was we collected baby
hair samples from people's scrapbooks so
we had baby hair going back 50 60 years
dated because everybody knew how old
their kid was and they knew and we
analyzed the hair samples for arsenic
and chromium and then we plotted out
where they were when the head sample was
taken and how close they were to some
contaminated Wells and because we did a
fairly short of radiation after a while
the activities died down we gave the
samples back and so that was and we
found that it didn't correlate with the
well water or
the time when the contamination was the
worst which made people happy sort of in
retrospect you know that the
contamination from that area didn't get
into the weld water so anyway that one
of my samples and the hair is a pain in
the neck to work with so I hope none of
you give me hair samples I won't run
them okay so let's go down the hall this
way you all got to follow so this is I
mean it's just a fine powder and it's
fly-ash from a coal-fired power plant
fly-ash means the ash that goes up the
smokestack as opposed to bottom ash
which is what falls down and so they
collect whole you know hundreds of
kilograms of fly ash just homogenize it
sieve it send it out to all a lot of
labs to analyze NIST is really good at
this take all the data and so this is
this ash is characterized for about
twenty elements or so so when I run my
samples if I were to run your samples
with standards I'd run a little bit of
this five six seven milligrams and I
know what the the concentrations are on
this and so that's how I do the
comparative method and so I got you know
this and they all look the same you know
this is some soil from Montana next to a
mine so it's nicely contaminated with
some metals this is my IAEA mercury in
hair standard but again it's just a
little powder and this is kind of what
everybody uses for standards and you
just kind of have a whole collection of
them and depending on what elements
you're looking for you try to mix and
match them so you get cover what you
want without having to run five or six
off my hot lab or one of my hot labs you
guys last week or whatever it was I came
by so this is the rabbit those of you
who weren't there these are I call these
these are called rabbits because it's
the little thing that runs through
the pneumatic tube you guys are doing
parable nips later today yeah when
you're sitting at the control panel
there's a button I think it's to the
left and it says insert rabbit and
that's what this is referring to for
longer radiations there's a spot in the
basement in the reactor where they can
get these and they send them into the
radiation location for shorter
radiations like what you guys are going
to be doing in a month I send them in
from here that's okay you just don't
want to bump into that thing yeah so
this is one end of the pneumatic system
and so I can put a couple of samples in
here I stick it in that little tube
there call a control room and say okay
turn a bunch of knobs and switches and
whatnot and it goes shook and in about
15 seconds it's next to the rillette
neck to the core of the reactor in the
graphite I usually run shorts I'll
usually irradiated for about 10 minutes
we usually let the sample sit in the
reactor for a little while so the very
short half-life stuff decays away and
then it comes back out here and the
whole thing just kind of shoots out
there and bounces into here and then pop
open the rabbit and in that hood pull
the samples out I usually try to
repackage the samples so this is partly
why I asked for stuff that's kind of one
or two good solid pieces because then I
can take it out of whatever it was
radiated in put it in a clean bag or
vial and that way we don't have to do a
blank subtraction for the sample that
makes sense because otherwise if I take
like a little vial in or radiate it and
then count it I'll also have whatever
elements are in the vial on the thing
for when I'm running standards and this
is when you won't if we're not running
standards you don't have to worry about
this that powdered standard stuff I'd
never get that out of a bag because
you'd never get all of it out and I'd
have contamination everywhere if ice
cutting open those bags so I do have to
do a bag correction for those so when I
do in a radiation I always radiate a few
just empty bags and then you do a
correction for those because the bags of
God aluminum and antimony and a bunch of
things in them yeah and so then like I
take a couple of samples I throw them in
a lead pig so I got a whole bunch of
these floating around and I run it down
the hall and throw it on a detector and
we count it when are we doing shorts
I'll radiate two samples at a time
because I have two detectors what I used
to have four detectors I ran four
samples at a time so you irradiated
repackage it count it
while that sample those pair of samples
are counting you come down here you are
radiate the next two so that you know
you're just kind of always radiating and
counting I usually do a ten minute of
radiation for shorts I'll do it fairly
quick count five minutes right after I
get the sample down there and that's
looking for stuff with half lights sort
of under 10 minutes the shortest half
life I look for is for aluminum it's two
and a quarter minutes but things usually
have a lot of aluminum in them so I see
if I see aluminum pretty well for shorts
I'll count all the way up to about
sodium which is almost fifteen hour
half-life longer stuff I'll do a longer
radiation account there's a little
overlap on my shorts and Long's that
helps me do QA on things and if I run
two standards I'll check you know the
concentrations from one standards the
other there's another little q8 thing I
don't know what else we got
questions it's pretty straightforward
yeah what do we got oh yeah yeah okay
yeah there was a lot of archeology that
did you know naa got used for that a lot
I don't think we ever did it here Fred
Frye who's a professor retired now from
EOBs Earth atmospheric and Planetary he
did a lot of geological samples and yeah
there's I forget where it was it they
did all the archaeology one of the
things na is really good for is rare
earth elements which are hard to measure
by other methods I mean I didn't get
very low limits on that and by picking
out various rare earths and the ratios
you can help identify where things are
from in the world
if you give me a little tiny piece of it
I mean you know I mean the well see
that's the rabbit so it's definitely got
to fit in there the thing I really like
yeah excuse me where's my vials yeah I
used to have some smaller ones up here
but so you know that's should definitely
fit in one of those like to see that guy
my usual description of what size sample
I like is if it's a piece that you would
pick up with a pair of tweezers so not
too small to pick up with you know to be
able to find so no powders but you know
and you could maybe get it with your
fingers but 20 milligrams 50 milligrams
100 milligrams is just in the right
ballpark
nope doesn't matter but we'll look at
what comes in and yeah I might veto some
things or not we'll see well we got
bricks everywhere
so when I when I get the sample out of
there
I do the repackaging in here and so this
is just shielding between the samples
I'm working on and myself I don't have
my toe simony on now but I usually I've
got the symmetry and a ring badge and
then it kind of comes over here and I do
the this is where the heat sealer is so
I can I you know heat seal it here and
then I'll have a pig over here oh yeah
these are just painted lead bricks and
you know these have been here longer
than I have so and you don't sometimes
things just are somewhere and you never
move them yeah these they think older
than me too so
this lab has been doing any a she's I
don't know since the 70s I think so
anybody else
the full-size bricks this like that size
2 inches by 4 inches by 8 inches weighs
about 25 pounds there's usually a bunch
of them floating around that one's not
quite full-size you know they're heavy
they're lit okay when people ask me
because I work in the reactor as well
they say is there anything dangerous in
the reactor the dangerous thing is
dropping wet bricks on your feet that's
why I've got steel toast if I miss the
toe yeah probably break my I don't want
to think about it and they move much
bigger things in the reactor when you if
you toward the reactor yet yeah so I
mean there's that giant crane there and
they move you know five tonne pieces of
shielding and that's the other dangerous
thing and there's dropping really big
things we've never dropped anything that
big I think somebody dropped a steel
plate on their foot once that was about
the worst of it
you know like four foot half inch steel
boom yeah okay good yeah you know when
people trip and fall off ladders and
it's the usual industrial accidents
okay good yeah yeah I mean I've broken a
few but not not here
sure and I'll see you guys in a month or
something and have fun running the
reactor oh good day folks you guys are
here to do an experiment on the reactor
it's in two parts the first part is
raising reactor power
the first is raising reactor power using
a low earth absorber called a regulating
rod and then the second part will be
lowering reactor power using a high
worth absorber and the high worth
absorber things would move much faster
and we don't want to run into a chance
of you accidentally going too high so
that's why we use the low worth absorber
on the way up and a high worth absorber
on the way down okay and I just want to
show you the controls with me today is
Tim to actually do this experiment we
need to licensed people in here one that
least has a senior reactor operator both
Tim and I are both senior licenses so
that we have that covered the only way
you can actually do these manipulations
are if you're in my training program on
the training supervisor for the facility
or you're in a program that needs you to
actually operate the reactor and the
program you guys are in fits that
definition okay so I just want to show
you some of the controls of the reactor
first we have our shin blade controller
this basically moves one of six shim
blades at a time the one that's selected
has a slide on it and we can change
which one selected with the shim blade
selector switch this switch here is a
regulating rod this one will allow you
to move the regulating rod up and down
our blades are fixed speed meaning they
can only move at a at the exact same
rate at all times
moving the shim blade in upward
direction or the regulator rod in upward
direction take underhand grip and pull
up or twist upwards until it stops
we get just a little bit doesn't move
anything you have to move all the way
until it stops and then the absorber
will move in the outward direction if
you want the blade to stop just release
it it's spring-loaded and will go back
to the neutral position and stop moving
if you want to drive something in the
inward position take an overhand grip
and twist downwards and that will drive
the absorber in once again let go it'll
snap back up and stop the motion of the
blade while the regulating rod the
experiment we're doing is basically
changing rack of power by half a
megawatt and we're currently at 500
kilowatts we're gonna bring it bring the
reactor up to one megawatt and then
bring it back down to 500 kilowatts so
before we can do this you have to log
into our log book as a trainee on
console we'll show you the proper way to
make the entries as you make those
entries you'll go ahead and then do the
actual movement itself okay so the first
one is going to be using a regulating
rod to move the rack for power up what's
the reactive power we have about nine
different instruments that tell us what
the reactive power is at all times but
the ones we're going to be paying
attention to our channel 7 and channel 9
these two channels are what we use to
basically tell us what the reactive
power is channel 7 is what we control
our automatic control act if you watch
the regulating rod you'll see it move up
and down on its own that's because it's
changing power based on what it sees
channel 7 is doing so if channel 7 sees
that the power level is going too low
it'll cause a regular rod to drive
outwards to increase the amount of
neutrons making the rack part of the
world
channel 9 is a linear power channel and
it basically tells us what the power
level is based on our chart that we
create so it's not showing you megawatts
or kilowatts or anything like that it's
showing you a current coming from a
chamber and that current is then
converted into megawatts and so forth
so right now we're at 500 kilowatts 8.5
micro amps on this channel and that's
8.5 micro amps equals 500 kilowatts
you're gonna be bringing the rapper up
to 1 megawatt and since it's a linear
it'll be double that so 17.1 now you
want to be careful when you raise
reactive power so when you start to add
power to the reactor by raising the
regulating rod you don't want to bring
it you don't want to keep raising it
until you reach your value because you
have to actually stop the power increase
as well so we have two rules that we
have to follow one at the power level or
at we have period there at the period
the reactor period is the amount of time
it takes you out to power to increase at
the power level we're at we're not
allowed to go shorter than a hundred
second period okay so here is one of
three period meters one here one here
which is selectable between two
different meters so as you're pulling up
the regulating rod one of the things you
have to watch is to make sure that the
reactor period doesn't go shorter than
100 second period if it does you have to
stop following blades the other thing we
have to watch for is to make sure that
the power level Channel nine doesn't
exceed where you're going to not only
not exceed but we also want to make sure
that you can actually control the
reactor it's called feasibility of
control and what that means is when you
get to about 80 percent of the power
level you're going to since we're going
up to one megawatt that's about 800
kilowatts you want to be able to drive
the absorber in and hold the absorber in
you'll buy the regulating rod inwards
and watch that channel nine value it'll
slow until it actually starts to go down
again once it reaches that value and you
see it going down you now know that you
could control the reactor and keep it
from going away rack power increasing
continuously
so what we're going to do is have you
when you reach 80% of the power level
you're going to which happens to be 800
kilowatts you're going to start
increasing or lengthening a period by
driving the absorber back in the
regulating rod and you'll keep holding
it in on
you see the number not only stop
increasing but actually go down a little
bit as soon as you see it go down a
little bit let go the regulating rod you
haven't stopped the power at this time
you just increased how or you decrease
how fast it's going up and then the
power level still go up but a much
slower rate than it was before and once
it reaches the power level you want to
stop at the one megawatt keep driving
the regulating rod in to hold it at that
power level once you're at that power
level you're going to make an entry in
the log book that basically says you
made it to the power level you're going
to and then we'll go down in power so
once again you make an entry in the log
book that says I'm going to lower
reactor power to 500 kilowatts and then
this time we'll use a shim blade the
shim blade is worth a lot more than a
regulating rod about ten times the shim
blade excuse me of the regulating rod so
things will happen much faster so you'll
be able to drive this in and rack power
will change much faster than before same
thing as you get closer to the power
level you start at 500 kilowatts you
don't want to under shoot and go too low
so at around 600 kilowatts or so start
driving a shim blade out to slow down
how quickly the power levels going down
okay and once you get back to the place
where you started at we'll use a regular
rod regulating rod to fine tune it to
keep the rack of power where we want to
be there'll be another logbook entry and
your time round console will be
completed okay so with us today we
actually have to MIT soon so our
actually my training program and they've
actually done a lot of these
manipulations already Sarah let's go
I'll take I'll take those
so normally we sit and watch if at any
time you don't feel comfortable doing
something let us know we'll ask you just
to take your hands off the console and
we'll take care of doing whatever is
necessary to keep the reactor safe but
be aware we're a factor of 10 lower than
where we would automatically scram at so
it'd be very difficult for you to get to
someplace where it would cause a problem
without us being able to stop it okay so
our normal I don't know if you want to
move or anything but we the supervisor
normally sits like kind of right in your
way so that they can keep an eye on
what's happening okay
you can go ahead and make the
announcement that your that were
starting power manipulations and then
the last verse to make announcing that
we're done with our manipulations
right now the reactors on auto control
and when we do these manipulations the
reactor opera is going to take manual
control that'll cause an alarm to come
in and this only happened for the first
time so one of the things she's going to
do after she makes our logbook entry no
we'll do that at the end is she'll take
manual control the reactor and alarm
will come in on console and she'll
answer it and that should be the only
time you hear this alarm because we'll
leave it on manual control until the
final participant has done their
manipulations
okay
now she's pulling up the Reg rod all the
way you see the Reg rod number going up
the period is getting shorter it's no
longer at infinity it's going closer to
a hundred second and channel seven and
channel nine are increasing in value
another way you can see it is we have a
display on in front of the operator
those three displays two of them are
just for evaluation only we don't
actually use those to control the
reactor they're based on a system that
haven't been approved yet but we're
testing them to see how well they work
so you can see that the power level on
the far left is going up the middle one
is showing what the actual power level
we saw a 500 kilowatts sorry up to 630
kilowatts and increasing and the period
that was at an infinity is now around
160 seconds
so she's watching until she sees the 800
kilowatt value here on channel 7 channel
9 and she started to drive in the
regular rod so she's slowing down how
quick the power increases bowing and you
see the period lengthening it's no
longer at 150 160 seconds it's going
closer to infinity again so she's
proving that she could stop the reactor
power if she continued driving in this
regulating rod
No
she's closing in on the one megawatt
one of the things the note is that when
she started the wrecker I was around Oh
300 oh three ten and she's almost right
back to there when you raised reactive
power you basically open up a valve and
let more neutrons in and when you get to
the place where you want to be you
basically close that valve again
so you basically add reactivity and then
stop that reactivity in addition by
bringing the absorbers back to about
where they started from now okay one
megawatt go ahead and make your logbook
entry
so once again she has experience she's
been doing startups and power
manipulations for a while when the rest
of you sit down here will guide you
through those the logbook entries that
she's making uh so forth
yeah
30.6
yep so one of the things that could
change the reactor is xenon it's a
poison that built into the reactor while
we operate poison in that it absorbs
neutrons not leading the fission and it
has to make ways of being made in two
ways of having removed one is direct
from fission and the other is decay
that's the way it's produced the way it
goes away is basically absorbing a
neutron and decaying to another isotope
and
okay
yep his blade sucks and what happens is
when we lower reactive power the way we
remove most of the xenon from Verna
basically the neutrons being absorbed by
the by the fission process the the fact
that we don't have the reactor at a very
high power means that the amount of
xenon in the core isn't being removed so
we actually start the power would
actually want to go down on the tunnel
so you would have to do a lot or regions
and for a while that's a very large
amount of reactivity that has to be
compensated for for this experiment
though we actually shut down the reactor
yesterday and we started up early this
morning so it's not a big factor as it
normally would be after doing one of
these
blowing reactor power
now I think we'd be able to get at least
one more person
so once again she's long reactor power
you can see on the period meter she's at
a negative period and the reactor power
is decreasing she's almost at 500
kilowatts she's uh driving the absorber
out again to slow down how quickly the
power levels going down and when she's
done the shin blade will end up about at
the same point where started to thirteen
point four two inches out of the bottom
of the core
we closed cops say what the regarding
you two
30.8
okay and that's the end of the exercise